welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you finished
the third season of chilling Adventures
of Sabrina then chances are you want to
know more the season ended on a big
cliffhanger and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down
everything we know so far about the
upcoming part 4 this includes why this
show is a guarantee the release date
cast and potential plot there will be
heavy spoilers here in regards to the
third seasons ending so if you haven't
had a chance to watch it yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
chilling Adventures of Sabrina part 4
[Music]
okay now a big question that's floating
about at the moment is will there even
be a part for a lot of seasons on
Netflix such as the oae daredevil
Jessica Jones Luke Cage and so on get
cancelled halfway through their run and
the streaming service has stated in the
past that they do this because new shows
bring in new subscribers whereas already
established ones don't
this is why a lot of Netflix shows get
shut down after season three however
Sabrina part four is already guaranteed
as back in 2018 the broadcasting giant
ordered both a third and fourth season
it was stated at the time by The
Hollywood Reporter that both parts would
consist of eight episodes we've already
had this with part three so it looks
like part four will also have the same
amount upon the announcement showrunner
Roberto
Aquarius akasa whose name of definitely
butchered said the following in regards
to part three and part four praise Satan
I'm so grateful to my partners at Warner
Brothers Netflix Balanta television and
Archie Productions for supporting this
darker vision of the world's most famous
Teenage Witch I'm thrilled to be
continuing to tell Sabrina chilling
adventures with our incredible cast and
crew led by the unstoppable Kiernan
Shipka so we now know that path 4 is
already a given but when will it be
released well it may surprise you to
learn that Sabrina is apparently already
filming the production and part 3
wrapped in October and it was stated at
the time that filming would pick up just
two weeks later
therefore part 4 is already probably a
lot of the way through its shooting
schedule and it could possibly be
announced soon that it has finished
filming Kiernan Shipka has been posting
a flurry of images onto her instagram
that look like they're from set or at
least the production so is possible that
things are well underway but with the
project far into its production when
will it be released well whilst we don't
have a definite date we can use the past
to judge well we can expect to see the
entry there was a six-month gap between
parts 1 & 2 which were filmed similar to
parts 3 & 4 these first two parts were
together as were the latter so we can
use this to guesstimate the upcoming
release date Netflix shows tend to
release annually
however Sabrina is its own entity and
therefore we can assume that season four
will be releasing in summer 2020 so it
doesn't look like we'll be waiting that
long which is great news for fans of the
show as it did end on a big cliffhanger
that I'm sure many people want to see
resolved all of the notable cast members
are returning including of course
Kiernan Shipka Sabrina Miranda Otto as
aunt Zelda and Lucy Davis as Aunt Hilda
Chance pidemo is back as Ambrose tatty
Gabrielle is returning his prudence and
Russ Lynch will be reprising the role of
Harve Theo is back Rosalind - and Nick
scratch is set to return in a major way
for part 4 as for the villains Michelle
Gomez will be back as Ward well / Lilith
and Richard Coyle will be returning his
father Blackwood part 4 is also
including extras such as Caliban who we
saw Sabrina Trapp in episode 8 the
character is likely angered by this and
it's possible at his quest for the
throne could see him going head to head
with Sabrina or rather the version of
her that is now the Queen as for the
plot itself we do have some hints about
what it could be about and it sounds
that they're really going all out with
it before we get into that though I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts and chilling Adventures of
Sabrina part for the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of February
and the set will be shipped out from
then - ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part ok so
part three ended with a lot of things up
in the air after Sabrina ended up using
time travel to go and save Greendale
from the pagans Sabrina was supposed to
allow herself to be trapped by Caliban
in order to continue the time loop and
stop a paradox from being created
however the characters stopped this a
nurse created two versions of herself it
was a pretty crazy ending and with this
she was able to please both sides of a
life sabrina has always been wanted as
the queen of hell and this lineage is
honed it here for the majority of a life
she's always just wanted to be normal Oh
have
friends and sway away from this but
Satan wouldn't allow her to do it
however with her doppelganger Sabrina
was able to live the best of both worlds
and one version of her went on to real
hell whilst the other continued with her
normal life we theorized that this
double inhale will become jealous of
Sabrina and that she would probably end
up going head-to-head with the character
Lilith did dress eff a war and we do
know from the alternate timeline that
Caliban tried to turn earth into the
10th circle of hell after being led by
both Satan and the bearer of his child
therefore it is possible that this new
Sabrina could end up following the same
path but rather than going head-to-head
with the pagans end up going against her
alternate version this time paradox is
clearly going to cause big problems and
the showrunner explained how the season
will work with two versions of the
character running around in an interview
with TV Guide they said the following I
can tell you that the temporal paradox
that happens at the end of a finale is
something that we will be playing with
in part 4 and as usual with Sabrina
something that seems innocent goes
catastrophically wrong and creates more
drama we will definitely be revisiting
that paradox in part 4 the twist did
anger some people and on my last video
which I'll link at the end I did see a
lot of people commenting that it felt
like a cop-out however this does have
basis in the source material and when
discussing this aspect of the season the
showrunner stated I will say though that
there is a very proud tradition in the
history of Sabrina in the comics and the
Melissa Joan Hart version of Sabrina
having a twin so we will be adding that
to the mythology in a pretty unique way
I hope so it does look like they will be
playing with this quite a lot and though
it did say that the two versions could
end up going to war at least we'll get
some fun with it beforehand in regards
to one of the other cliffhangers namely
Lilith's pregnancy the creator stated
that this would also return in part four
they said at the end of part three
Lilith secured a tentative stay of
execution her journey moving forward
will be how to leverage that baby to get
power back from Lucifer and to get that
much closer to the throne that's very
much in play for her for part 4 and now
that Sabrina is ruling in hell it gives
us a chance to play
a demonic version of the royal family in
Lucifer we will see someone who is
grooming his firstborn to be a real
monic sabrina spent a lot of time
avoiding that
but what Lucifer wants basically is to
pass the family business on to Sabrina
and mentor her so it does look like
we'll be seeing a lot more of hell Satan
was pretty much relegated to being
trapped inside Nick and then later
father Blackwood for the majority of
part 3 so this would be a good
opportunity to bring him into the show
properly we've not really seen how he
acts as a dad as he was revealed to be
Sabrina's father in part two and then
trapped by the end of it there wasn't
really a big opportunity for him to show
the way that he would really go on with
the character and this I really hope
that part four focuses on this which by
the sounds of it it will say yeah that's
great news though we will be seeing a
lot of Hell it also looks like we'll be
seeing at least some of heaven just just
a minor glimpse probably or maybe just a
bit the interview with the show and I
ended with them staying without spoiling
too much we will get a hint of heaven
yes so it looks like there's a lot to
look forward to we still don't know what
was in father Blackwood's egg and what
kind of creation he's unleashed in the
world but no doubt this will pop up in
part 4 overall I'm really excited for
the show and I enjoyed the 3rd season
and have had a lot of fun with the run
overall I'm glad they're doing it in
parts with shorter production schedules
as it means that the wait between
entries isn't too long which is great
news for fans like myself who could
happily binge watch your season of the
show in a day hopefully the trailer for
part 4 is here before we know and make
sure you keep yourself locked into the
channel for more updates as they come in
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the upcoming season and what
you want to see in it comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please give it a thumbs up and if
you want to see more videos on Sabrina
then make sure you click are breakdown
of the third season and it's ending
after this we go over the big
cliffhanger and give out theories on
what could be happening in the next
season so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to making videos like this you
get access to content early and can
suggest video topics and breakdowns and
if you want to chat to us after the show
either follow us at Definition YT or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with everything
we do and have you spoilers and
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]